مساعد محافظه اصفهان لشؤون السياسيه
والامنيه والاجتماعيه حصوله اي حادث امني
في المدينه الليله الماضيه مشيرا الى
تقارير المنتشره في وسائل الاعلام قائلا
انها غير صحيحه يذكر ان وكاله الانباء
الايرانيه حذفت ايضا خبر اسقاط مسيره كانت
تقترب من مجمع تابع لوزاره الدفاع كانت
وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه قد ذكرت ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت الليله الماضيه
طائره مسيره اقتربت من مبنى مجمع امير
المؤمنين اتابع لوزاره الدفاع في اصفهان
من دون سقوط اي ضحايا او اضرار وفي يناير
المضي قالت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه انها
احبطت هجوما بثلاث طائرات مسيره استهدف
مصنعا عسكريا في اصفهان لم يسفر عن ضحايا
وانما الحق اضرارا طفيفه بسقف المصنع
من طهران معنى الجزيره نور الدين الدغير
نور الدين اذا
الخبر بدايه من وكاله تسنيم اسقاط هذه
المسيره ثم نفي من مساعد
محافظ اصفهان كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذا
التضارب في في الاخبار موجوده المسيره ام
غير موجوده
نعم حسن اذا ما تمعنا في التفاصيل الصادره
سواء في ما صرح به المساعد السياسي
لمحافظه اصفهان او في النص الصادر
بالوكالات الايرانيه خاصه تسنيم او وكاله
الانباء الايرانيه التي حدثت الخبر فيما
بعد ذلك يتحدث المسؤول الامني بمحافظه
اصفهان بان المدينه لم تشهد اي عمل امني
بليله عبس بمعنى اخر بانه لم يكن هناك اي
عمل املي يستهدف اي منطقه من المناطق هناك
في اصفهان وهذا المسؤول هو مسؤول رفيع
مسؤول عن الجهه عن الملفات الامنيه
والملفات السياسيه بمحافظه اصفهان
فبالتالي هو ينفي ان يكون هناك حدوث امني
او حدث امني وقع بمدينه اصفهان او استهدف
منطقه ما اذا ما انتقلنا الى الشق الثاني
من هذه الروايه ومن هذه السرديه وهي مساله
ما صدر عن الوكالات حتى الوكالات لم تتحدث
عن عمل امنيه او تحدث عن هجوم تحدثت عن
اقتراب مسيرات او مسيرات صغيره وبالتاكيد
ربما قد تكون بما يعرف
قد اقتربت من مجمع لوزاره الدفاع حتى هذا
المجمع لم تعرف هويته وكل الاحتمالات تشير
على انه مجتمع سكني ولم يكن مجتمع صناعي
وهنا تبدا التاويلات الاساسيه حينما نتحدث
عن اقتراب هذه المسيره من مجمع تابع
لوزاره الدفاع هنا يمكن الحديث عن ثلاث
احتمالات لهذه المسيره الاحتمال الاول ان
تكون هذه المسيره هي مسيره هجوميه
بمتفجرات كما حدث في الهجوم السابق الذي
شهده مقر تابع لوزاره الدفاع بمسيارات
استهدفت مقر تابعه لها بانفجارات
وباستهدافها من قبل قوات الدفاع الجويه
المتمركزه هناك وهناك الاحتمال الثاني وهي
ان تكون هذه المسيرات هي مسيرات ربما
للرصد للمراقبه للتجسس ولم تكن لها طبيعه
هجوميه للهجوم على هذا المقر وهناك
الاحتمال المطروح والذي يطرح في الكثير من
الاوقات هنا انه باعتبار بانها مسيره
صغيره الحجم فربما قد تكون من ضمن
المسيرات التي يمتلكها العديد من
المواطنين الايرانيين ويستعملونها كثيرا
هنا للتسليه وباعتبار انها اقتربت من مجمع
سكني او من مجمع تابع لوزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه ربما تم التعامل مع بحساسيه اذا
كل هذه الاحتمالات مطروحه على الطاوله لكن
بكل تاكيد اذا ما حاولنا الربط بينما قاله
المساعد السياسي لمحافظه اصفهان ومع هذه
الاحتمالات ومع طبيعه الخبر المنشور على
الوكالات الايرانيه ينتفي ربما العمل
الامني اذا ما تحدثنا في سياق العمل
الانساني من قبيل الترفيه او حتى عمل
التجسس وعمل رصد المنطقه عبر هذه المسيرات
غير مراسله الجزيره من طهران شكرا جزيلا